kingdom
episode two
season two episode two to the tutu
yes that's what i said
guys
you know what we're gonna do let's just
watch it hit that like button and thanks
to prepper for helping set this down
they just been running all night yep
if this were an anime there would be a
theme song there
[Music]
it's an action episode
it's quiet
too quiet
he's out there is he no it's a mislead
it's gotta be
[Music]
you clever you smart jake
[Music]
oh no
he's sick someone on them
[Laughter]
family reunion kill your daddy
oh
it's quite a predicament yeah
god i love their use of lights and
shadows
funny i was about to say the same thing
oh my god his hands on the actual
sexy part of the blade yeah
dad it's me
can't your sword cut through the windows
or something no i gotta be able to cut
through some of these screens
i wonder if the same actor plays the
zombie that's a good question
he really took that to heart
oh man he's going to look like the man
who killed the king yeah there's no way
this ends well
oh guys you got the number advantage
oh
[Music]
oh so close
oh
[Music]
mvp my dude
[Music]
please don't tell me he killed him
yep he did god damn it
[Music]
oh
that plan quickly went south yeah
that guy's a master tactician that
hocked you
so
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
now there's just a mountain of dead
babies in there
wow you guys are good
[Music]
gonna stash these bodies quick
that's why it's important not to panic
don't make me commit treason right here
don't put clues together like that
our prince just waited a couple more
minutes
my
[Music]
together
all those labor pains suck huh yeah man
she's really looking terrible right now
congratulations
be happy
it's not far-fetched for the majesty to
be resurrected
haven't you guys seen stuff
happening in the last
couple days
come on slip him something
[Music]
oh man we gotta learn how to write in
korean you can be so much more efficient
yeah
break down immediately
yes
i don't like that shotgun
oh it's on
you son of a [ __ ]
come on man
come on
who do you get did you get him
whoa
oh no
damn it
you can't be shitty
all
the shots
to miss
oh that's bad
[Music]
oh now it'd be a great time for some
zombies oh she helped unleash them
she helped unleash them yes
nice
yes i knew it oh i knew it i [ __ ]
knew it
knew it i was like give me the
resurrection plant
oh god let them see
what a rewarding face
go come on go
it's gonna end it isn't it freaking know
this [ __ ]
give us one reward
keep going boromir you got this
this dude gets two crazy deaths not good
enough
unleash the beast
yes yes yes yes yes yes that's what i'm
talking about
chow down my guy
[Music]
another great final shot what a great
shot
yeah
your final shot i'm so glad to not end
i know i don't know we're just chasing
i'm so glad that after so much bad luck
because a little good luck in return
that's what i'm talking about man
even crown prince was like oh
oh no oh god oh god what have i done oh
my god
i know i've been doing this all week but
no lord anjon is smart man
even with like getting 50 centered in
his final
i'm gonna lift this bar over the door
and i'm gonna go in there
i'm gonna strategize i would still win
even in death i'm gonna win
yeah [ __ ] got this [ __ ] and he still
gets his revenge it works twofold yeah
truth revealed
gets vengeance after living in misery
for the past few years
everyone gets to see the truth
cho hawk
gets finally bitten he's going to turn
momentarily
son of a [ __ ] and somehow he's still
going to rule i am the first talking
zombie
i've retained most of my lifetimes worth
of knowledge and muscle memories i'm not
smarter they usually call me brainiac
bring me my bring me the queen console
to snack on
[Laughter]
and all those babies while you're at it
yeah but they're all gonna see the truth
now yeah man
this was this was a really cool roller
coaster because because yeah like they
start off in such a badass place and
then they bring you like their back and
forth of the whole chess game between
the crown prince's crew
and uh cho hawk jews crew just like
it's really devastating at points and
they're really great at pushing you into
that hopeless like it's good because
like
you know as much as it's been a hard and
long journey and you want those moments
of victory like the way they played it
here like for that final moment like
really really accentuated
just how much desperation goes into all
this yeah yeah that's true
i agree
those action scenes are shot different
mm-hmm kind of a little more pulp yeah a
little more pulp in your o.j in this
episode i'd say a lot more zooms a
little bit more zest and blood sweats
from the slicing and dicing and yeah the
the zooms and uh
a couple of really good shutter speed
tracking shots here and then the finale
yeah like when the guards are breaking
out you get that personal mode over half
and then before lord on yon and the
other are for uh you know junctions
no he just has one motive that they
don't share but yeah
but
you know he has
rallying them up to fight together
so pissed when he lost but i like how
that actually worked out in their favor
how the blood splat on the one guy
on uh
led to uh
led to him being charged at yeah it's
like it's an alley-oop it's like you
think he doesn't get his revenge but
then he assists directly in a dual
revenge yes yeah but i still like well
man
this guy never misses it
what happened there that guy just
stepped in at the right time i must have
been panicking moment of truth you know
you only get one shot man he did not
miss your chance to blow i'd get a man
i'd crack under pressure too
absolutely would
but yeah it was a good episode it was
cool would've liked a little bit of uh
crown prince grieving a little bit over
the dad tabbed it more yeah and for such
a short episode by comparison you think
they might have a little more time for
that but
then yeah i don't really care uh
because i
i don't uh i don't know i don't know the
king
well
yeah and i mean
there is a quality where um
i don't know like
with the crown prince he is kind of like
a
less prominent throughout this episode
like there are some very distinct
moments of his
and some i don't know it feels like he's
operating kind of in the background or
in the underscores of this episode and a
lot of other people get the main focus
because there's only so much he can do
you see in korean words because
from my american eyesight it looks like
you're you're using okay i'm going to
talk an american dumb language
looks like shapes to me okay and it
looks like you speak in shapes in korean
i don't know what you the same
terminology letters i'm assuming in some
way maybe i think we have 27 letters and
then we form them into words and i don't
really know how
the lang korean language works my point
being he cannot take water dip it and
write that in english
no
then he'd be writing there for a long
time to write that but
here it looks for my again american dumb
eyes looks like he's writing like two
shapes that say take the resurrection
plan
resurrect him yeah i don't know very
much about how
a lot of like would just work and
especially like korean or anything like
that i i from the vague amounts that i
think i've been told there is a certain
amount of
like
you use different lines and shapes and
combine them and i feel like one
formation can be either a whole word or
maybe even a couple ideas or something
depending so i think it
in my in my very vague very dumb guy
kind of summation i i think you can get
more ideas out
and more efficiently than in english
yeah
uh yeah but it fits uh perfectly well uh
i mean that that was that was really
enticing and it was really tight and
yeah i mean
my writer brain says you need to have
some grief scenes and then my audience
member sides like i don't really give a
[ __ ] about seeing them because i don't
know the king or the relationship and
it's such a zombie trope when your
logical brain's like you know it wasn't
your dad come on man you've known for a
long time yeah you know that's what i
mean you know for a while it wasn't like
you showed up and then you just saw it
you like just heard about it for the
first time like you've known for a while
your dad's dead yeah and you've been so
act on that a lot and he carries the
pain of the experience in his
performance and that's good enough yeah
he very much does and i like the little
flashback moments they had with him
you know haven't we seen those
flashbacks
uh i believe we have have we like with
that really bright sunlight backlighting
him looking yeah i believe we have okay
well even still i like seeing those
again at least
you got a snarky comment there you're
ready to go probably
i take it back i'm not happy to see them
again only new flashbacks you can have
totally i like i like seeing clips
repeated again too
there you go yeah i was just trying to
buy you some very creative find that
response
yeah if in fact if the next one could
just be a clip show yeah all the stuff
they didn't have time to film a new
episode so it's just a series of clips
you just get them all sitting around in
prison going oh man it has been a long
journey hasn't been hey remember when
you tied that one guy to the gate that
was great they throw some laugh tracks
in there yeah
yeah the friends we made along the way
man this isn't as funny without seeing
the surrounding context what you see
nope
uh but yeah that was it was good short
type sorry to lose lord anon he was a
good guy
but uh hey i mean he got more than i
like
i like the mystery side though yes the
of the uh that they're figuring out that
you have these team for a second i
forgot who the other guy was
when he was first investigating hearing
about the murder
i was like was this guy a good guy back
i don't remember her and
then i was like oh dead dead moms and
[ __ ] yeah he's good
he'll be good yeah yeah
though he's more probably on the cho's
side right now you know yeah they'll
uncover the truth and and that'll uh
yeah i love that juxtaposition as well
our protagonists are losing so much then
you've got this other part of like oh
here's a little hope you know it's
because they can keep their royalty so
sheltered
yeah and their machinations hidden i
really like that word yeah it's a good
word especially for political intrigue
yeah
tension's really palpable that's right
there's a percolating dress
and you're like everything it's its own
poem
[Laughter]
talking about a lot of things right
after a while you're out of different
words
we'll expand our vocabulary i'll pull up
my thesaurus later
fight different ways
give me some new words give me some new
words that mean the same thing yes so it
sounds smarter
uh yeah that was good stuff man good
stuff uh but my favorite moment is
is um
[Music]
when
now it's just so clever like throw them
in there with your dad and then when the
doors open you're the
murderer god so clever but i like i do
like when he looks up on the head he
just looks upon the prince
slowly turns his body
and he like
cries out in agony your majesty yeah or
my majesty yeah really selling it yeah
really milking it good is that how they
mourn back then like is that like a
ritualistic practice or are they all
really sad
it seems like it's a ritualistic
practice it's 99 of you couldn't know
the king that well i would guess that
it's probably a little bit of both i
don't know i mean
given
you know given the fact that it is a
much more simple and much more you know
hands-on time i guess the connection you
might feel to your ruler might be a bit
more like directly ingrained whereas you
know sure true but uh yeah i it kind of
feels like it would probably be both and
i i bet some people are truly despairing
and other people are just like this is
what we do
we mourn all together because you know
our king is a god
yeah very true yeah
all right guys well kingdom is done
thank you so much for being here you can
subscribe click that bell
say hi to your god for us and we'll
catch you guys soon